and that is the finale of The Voice
Blake Shelton pulling off the huge upset
last night his one finalist beating Adam
Levine's three Blake was just giddy
afterwards you know what he told me that
if he pulled this off it would be an
epic fail on Adam Levine's part and you
know what I like all of Adam's guys all
three of them you know what they're
really really good and I feel sorry for
them today but here's what don't feel
sorry no cuz you gotta feel good for the
new champ
Craig Wayne boy
when I first won I was looking around
everywhere to find my son that was the
most important thing to me at that
moment I finally found him
and they got him brought up I remember
they brought him up and then I had to
start seeing so it was like I got to
finish this song
the Nashville crooner has gone from
struggling single dad to two-year-old
son Jackson to the fourth singer of Team
Blake to ever win on the show making him
instantly recognizable on the street it
changes my life as a father in the fact
that I'll be able to provide for him
much better than I have in the past now
Craig says he plans to tour immediately
in hopes to play 250 plus dates next
year so get ready to hear the single
that broke the iTunes chart lie
Blake's best advice to me was just to
continue to be myself don't let people
change me and stick to my guns on Who I
am as a person
what is winning the voice do for these
contestants it's just a boost you know
because I think everybody in the finale
walks away with a big opportunity and a
fan base and a chance to make a record
for sure so when and the thing just
gives you that extra level of coverage
and that's important well he's getting
plenty of support from our team now
community who were definitely showing
the love at misty West says Craig you
made me start listening to country
congratulations you deserve it to me the
one of the coolest things that has
happened is the folks that say I don't
like country music or I don't listen to
country music but I love what you do now
from Craig's Nashville swagger two
pitbulls Miami flavor fire at all his
New Year's Revolution special is heating
up the NYE countdown on Fox live from
the MIAA when it's not cold and it's hot
what do people do they wear less clothes
you wear less clothes it's more sexy if
there's more sex is more energy more
energy more people watching going man I
wish I wasn't in Miami right now and
Pitt is mr. 305 but he's also a proud
Cuban American and we talked today after
President Obama announced that he was
making steps to normalize relations with
Cuba and Pitt said he really hopes that
happened he's holding out hope for
because his biggest dream is to perform
at the malecón in Cuba
you